When people don't do things,
it's not because they can't.
It's not even because they don't want
to.
It's because of the way they are.
Focusing on what I call chunking things.
When people don't follow through,
here's what they do.
Give you an example.
Who here believes exercise is very
important but you don't exercise
regularly?
Let me see a show of hands.
Raise your hand more hands than most of
us want to raise your hand right now.
Who here was really focuses or I should
say exercises regularly?
Raise your hand.
Regulate.
Okay,
great.
Who here does not exercise regularly
even though you believe it's important
just beach with.
Okay,
great.
So let's see what the difference is
here.
A person who does not exercise
regularly,
I want you to raise your hand and I want
you to tell me why you don't exercise
regularly would be truthful.
Okay?
Yes sir.
I don't have the top guy.
Is that true?
He even knows it's not true.
He's going to answer your first.
No.
But if feels like he doesn't have the
time,
cause time is emotion and he's got so
many other things,
he is focused on getting results in the,
adding this to the list seems like a
lot.
Right.
And the other things are very important
to him.
I guess business,
I don't have a time.
He has the time.
What's the real reason he doesn't do it?
Because of the way he thinks about
exercise.
When he focuses on what it would take to
exercise,
he does it very differently than someone
who follows through.
When you think about exercising,
what's involved,
okay.
Starts thinking about,
I gotta get to mile 14 or the London
marathon and that even the font of
trying to get to the 14th mile,
much less the 25th mile is like beyond
my imagination right now.
So he is what I call over chunked.
He's not thinking about what he wants.
He's thinking about what's painful.
You just saw a perfect example.
He's not even thinking about victory.
You're succeeding.
So the chance of him following through
on something that he associates major
pain too.
When are you can do something else right
now.
He can feel competent or successful.
APP is chances of falling through our
very limited.
How many would follow that?
Say Aye.
His focus is on failure.
His focuses on pain.
That's why he isn't following through.
Okay?
He's also focused on the 14th mile of a
marathon rather than today's workout.
Which one seems more daunting to you?
So when you think of what is,
and here's also what he's thinking
about,
he's thinking about the process,
not the outcome or result he wants.
And when you think about what it's going
to take the do something,
usually it takes a lot and you're not
going to want to do it.
So he's over chunked himself.
He's trying to eat the whale hall
without taking any smaller bites.
It seems too big for him.
So he says,
well,
I'll do it when later down my friends
will say later,
of course,
the problem with doing it tomorrow is
when you get to tomorrow,
Tomorrow's Today.
Tomorrow never comes.
So when you keep promising yourself,
by the way,
what does this do to you emotionally
when you keep breaking your own promises
with yourself or you keep failing to do
things that you know are important?
Does it increase your lens?
Some of certainty and confidence.
Know what it does?
Is it it?
And when you rode competency in one
area,
believe it or not,
it affects the other areas to do.
Believe me on that.
Don't believe me.
What about your own life experience?
Maybe not one area,
but it starts to be multiple areas.
It sure does.
Another reason why somebody has an
exercise or do anything is because they
don't just chunk it too big a chunk it
into many details.
I'll give you a perfect example.
So I asked somebody one time,
I said,
uh,
okay,
how important is exercises?
Oh,
exercise is extremely important.
Really?
Okay,
good.
And tell me why don't you exercise
regularly?
Well,
I and I just don't have time.
Okay.
Everybody gives that answer.
That sounds wonderful.
So tell me though,
don't tell me about how much time you
don't have,
tell me this.
When you think about exercising,
what do you think about,
which is a way of saying what do you
focus on?
And so this woman says to me,
well my gosh,
you know,
I mean I do.
What do you mean?
When I think about,
well,
let's say I said to you,
you,
you got to start exercising and I'm
going to put a gun to the head of your
children and I will do very horrible
things and hurt them badly.
If you don't exercise,
could you do it?
Oh yeah,
I can do it.
You know,
if I,
if you,
if some mafia person came here and said,
I'm going to kill your children,
you don't exercise every day,
how many things you can find a way to
exercise everyday no matter what your
time constraints may be.
So remember this,
remember this change is never a matter
of ability.
It's always a matter of motivation.
I'll say that again.
Change is never a matter of ability.
It's always a matter of motivation or
drive.
Having strong enough reasons.
If you've got a stronger,
the reason you could figure out the
time,
couldn't you?
So the biggest part of life and time
management is knowing what you want and
having enough reasons to follow through.
But there is one more piece.
If you make enough reason to fall
through and you'll you want,
but you make the task overwhelming,
you'll be overwhelmed.
So I said to her,
forget what I said,
let's just say you really going to start
exercising.
You're going to do it regularly.
How would you do it?
What,
what?
What's involved with exercising?
What's involved with exercise?
What do you focus?
He goes,
well,
if I was going to work out regularly,
I'd,
I,
I'd have to find a club to join.
I said,
okay,
so we watch it goes well,
but you want to know the whole process?
Yes.
Tell me the whole process of what it
would take an extra.
She goes,
oh my God,
I,
I'd have to,
I'd have to get on the web and search
for like all the exercise places around
my home and I,
you know,
didn't have to look through those and
see which one's probably closest or
which one is probably the nicest.
And I don't really know.
So I probably have to search on the web
and like read about it,
each of them and get a sense and see the
pictures of the place.
But of course,
you know it's never that way.
They really show it to you.
They always should have the best
pictures.
It's not really that nice.
So then I have to get in my car and I
got to find these places so you don't
have to google the location and look it
up.
And then I drive the I,
you know,
a lot of times instructions are wrong on
Google.
So sure enough I get the place,
it's not even the right place.
And then they have to coldplay,
somebody's cell phone there.
If they're called the place,
I can write down the directions.
Of course,
I probably don't have a pen.
I'm,
you know how it is when you're driving.
And so finally I get a pen and I drive
down the directions or try to remember
in my mind,
and I get to the place and now I've got
to get a ticket.
You know how you get that ticket?
And then I gotta go find a parking space
and then find a parking space.
Then what do I going to do now?
I got to go into this place and when you
go on the place,
you can't just go look around.
They want to escort,
you don't pay.
Some salesperson wants to score it me,
so I got to go with the salesperson.
They walked me around and they show me
the locker room and they show me this
and they show me that and they show me
all this stuff and then let's say I
won't even buy it here.
I get just give him a credit card.
Then when we fill out a little
application,
like I'm two years old again,
I'm in high school,
oh come on,
give me a break.
And then I fill out the application.
Now I got to pay him and then they want
to sell me a 10 million year membership
and I just want to try this for six
months.
And then after all that,
then they want to take a picture that
looks worse when you take it,
then your driver's license plus after
that.
Now what I do now,
I've got a flash.
The car going to work out and what I got
to do work out,
I had to take off all my clothes and I
got to hang them up in this tiny little
walker where my stuff doesn't really fit
and it's going to get wrinkled.
I know it's going to fall off and it's
going to get wrinkled and be terrible.
So let's say now I do that because now I
go to the first station,
I got to figure out which station to go
to.
So now they will probably want to give
me some trainers going to tell me what
to do.
But Let,
let's say,
dude,
I'm like,
oh,
I go to first nations,
somebody sitting,
some sweaty,
smelly person who gets up and they,
they got sweat.
All over sudden I gotta take my towel
and I got to wipe it all off and then,
and then I got to adjust the weight and
then I don't know what the right way it
is.
I got adjusted again and get the hassle
of figuring out how to Justin and I
finally do my exercise.
And then I got to wipe the thing off and
then I gotta go find the second station
and maybe there's somebody there,
maybe it's all sweaty and I don't know
the numbers and they have to like do all
these one station after station,
after station,
after station.
Now I got to go to the locker room and
take off my sweaty clothes,
which I'm going to put in a bag,
which I know is going to speak up my
car.
And then I got to go in and take a
shower and maybe I'll first do a steam
room or something,
but then I'm going to see body parts of
other people I don't even want to see.
And then they're not going to go on.
I've got to do my hair now,
do my makeup all over again,
start all over my makeup and do the
whole thing.
All these little pieces and they're
going to put on mine now wrinkle clothes
and now I can't even just leave.
I got to go to the front and I ain't got
to get my ticket stamps.
I don't have to pay for it.
They've got to find the car,
which I forgot where it is and then I'm
going to shortly the guy and then I
dried out.
That's what it takes to work out
well.
What does it take deed to do it?
What do you mean just do it well,
I don't know what you want.
Tell you.
Okay,
I know 12 places.
Let's go
well,
but what do you mean?
See eating is one chunk.
Exercising is 3,229
where every little step of,
well I got to do,
I think about all the consequences and
the elements and the pieces and that's
why they don't do it.
They're over chunked.
What you focus,
you feel what you feel.
You are moved to somehow actuate,
change a question,
change your life when it comes to
planning your life.
I want to get your learned to ask three
questions now and the first one is not
what am I going to do and how many
understand why now say hi.
The question one to ask yourself is what
do I want?
What's my outcome?
What's my result?
The word R,
p.
M.
The first one is to get you focused on
the target.
The target is not the activity.
The activity can change.
It's what the,
what's the result I'm after?
If you knew exactly what it is you
really want,
what you desire,
what you're really after,
clarity is power.
The more clear you are in specifically
what you want,
the faster your brain can get you there.
But if you're generally saying things
like,
what do I want?
Well,
you know I want more money.
Fine.
Here's a dollar.
Get outta here.
Did you achieve the outcome?
Yeah.
When you're that general,
you may be,
you think you're not getting your goal.
You are the way you language your goal.
Then when you think about it,
you're receiving it.
You know?
You know I,
you know,
I want to feel a bit better.
I want to lose some weight.
Finally,
I lost a pound.
You're done because your brain's like a
servo mechanism and a bomb and a
missile.
The old days you shoot a missile and the
target was going and if you miss the
trajectory,
you missed it.
Today.
What happens when the missiles not on
course?
What happens in locks onto the heat
signature and wants to do it moves and
follows it.
That's the way your brain is.
If it knows the outcome,
if it knows the result,
so rpm starts with I got another result.
This is a results planning system.
The rapid planning method.
You can think of it as a results
planning system.
I need to know the result I'm after
before I ever asked myself what to do.
That takes more time
but it's worth it now for time's sake.
I'm not going to do this with you right
now but I'll tell you when I do,
when I've taught this to people and I
got full weekend to do this and just
give you a picture.
If I asked you right now to write out
your name,
your full name.
Now some of you abbreviate your
signature but write out your full name
and have cursive.
Couldn't do that one time right at your
full name and curse it.
I can't even use the word cursive.
Is that really the word people still use
means in handwriting I guess,
but in cursive.
Just write it out in full name because
you can do this later on.
Now if I add you get with a partner and
you can try this later if you want.
I'm just going to tell you because I
don't want to take the time because they
have such limited time today and I have
your partner say to you with a stopwatch
here,
okay,
ready?
And I go,
go and you write it out and you told me
when you're done,
I go stop.
I write down how long that was.
So let's say you wrote out your
signature and it took five seconds and
then say,
ready,
write it out.
Ready,
go.
You told me we didn't stop and I write
down five seconds.
I have to do that 10 times.
You'll find in the beginning you'll be,
let's say six seconds.
I'm making it up.
Every signature is different and you
probably might get down to as little as
five seconds.
If you have like an iphone,
you can do it as a digital stopwatch.
You could see the middle seconds.
Then I say to you,
I want you guys to write every other
letter in cursive.
What would you write?
Half as many letters?
How long do you think it would take to
do it?
Half as much time.
Most of you will take twice as much time
in the beginning and then eventually,
what's interesting is if I do a 10 times
and the last two or three,
and this makes no logical sense,
and again,
I don't want to take the time to have
all of you do this 10 times,
10 times,
but you can do it on your own.
I'll just tell you the result.
In most cases,
even though you're doing half as many
letters,
you cut it by two thirds of the time.
There's something happens when you break
an whole pattern and you do it fresh.
Your brain over the years has learned
ways to move more rapidly since when you
did your original signature and you'll
do it in a third.
The amount of time.
It'll take twice as much at first and
then she'll across your third amount of
time.
Now,
let me tell you what I'm telling you.
This,
the system I'm calling a rapid planning,
nothing.
By the time I show it to you,
you're going to go,
this takes more time than just making my
to do list.
It will win.
When will it take more time when
initially,
but once you get it in your nervous
system,
it'll take you less time because your
brain will be thinking and outcomes and
not activities and when you think in
terms of outcomes and activities,
pretty soon some of the activities and
you'll see what lead me to do to get the
outcome.
You find a better way to get the outcome
quicker.
The how do you do that?
Yes.
Three questions.
Question one,
what is my result?
What is my outcome?
What does it I really truly want from
this?
If you're going back next week and you
say this next week,
what are the most important?
What outcomes for me to get this week in
my business?
And he was right.
Those outcomes are not your action
items,
the outcomes you,
if you do that and nothing else,
you'll be ahead of the game.
And if you just keep looking at those
outcomes every day,
how am I doing on that outcome?
Your brain will come up with ways to get
to that outcome.
I promise you.
Focus on outcomes,
not on activities.
Action for most people activities,
most people may mistake movement for
achievement.
They mistake action items.
Introduce for achievement.
We're after the achievement.
Are you with me on this?
Yes or no?
It's a different way of thinking and I
think all of you inherently have it,
but if you make this ritualized,
just like the things you've learned this
week,
they're all great,
but if you don't systematize them,
they'll work when you do them.
But if you systematize them,
right,
and you see like Mr. Holman here,
where he goes in and just does it and
does it make sure it's being done again
or what you've seen chet do or what I
do,
you just do it over and over again.
You don't miss it.
Now the results are geometric.
So I want to get you to systematize the
thinking,
whether you do it visually the way I'm
going to show you or not.
So first question,
what's the result from after?
What's the ultimate result?
What I want out of this week out of this
thing,
out of my business,
out of my life for my body,
and you want to be as what as possible
when you described that outcome,
that result as well as clear and
specific as possible,
generalities will confuse you so it
might take you longer than just right
now called So-and-so to think,
if I'm calling my my son,
I'm going to call Gerrick or I'm going
to call my brother.
This is what goes through my head before
I called always,
what's my outcome because I don't want
to just call them,
I want jerk to feel loved by his dad or
I'm thinking about what for?
How come I got to talk to him about this
thing that's out there.
I got to make sure I get through to him
on this because I want to guide him and
moving in this direction.
That's what I want to be as his father.
I want to,
I don't want to just Chit Chat.
I can do that too.
So if you think before every phone call
before every time you're planning your
day and you think before you have any
meeting,
what do you think?
The first thing I ask of anyone when we
sit down in the meeting is,
okay,
what are your,
what are your outcomes?
What are the outcomes to this meeting?
First thing I want to know because if I
know the outcomes,
guess a lot of meetings,
they're done pretty quick because I know
the outcome.
You don't have to go through all the
activities,
the sell me on it.
Just that's your outcome.
How do you want to do it?
Sounds good to me.
Rock.
That's how you make a meeting
productive.
I know a meeting for Dr Number,
the hours or time.
Sometimes it takes longer to the outcome
than you want,
but I'm going to get the outcome.
That's by the way,
what you see with me on stage,
that's my time is very,
it's based on an outcome.
I'm going to get that outcome.
I don't give a damn whether it's the
right time or not.
I want to do it at that time,
but I must deliver the outcome.
I'm going to get that.
And by the way,
how many like to have your company
focused on outcomes,
results and not activity?
Say I people say all the time,
well if you do,
you get that done.
Well do you want,
I left them an email.
I left him a voicemail.
I sent them three emails.
So in terms you heard that.
When that happens with me,
I'm like,
you know,
but I don't show it.
I just like really?
Wow.
That's fascinating.
We'll explain our about our culture.
It's about getting the result.
So I can help you if you can't figure
another way to do it.
But there may be 12 of the things we
might want to do.
Maybe they don't have the answer.
Maybe somebody else can give us the
answer.
The outcome was to get this information,
not to leave an email or 12 or three
voicemails that will not do any of us
any good.
How many faults.
Now,
whether you get the outcome or not,
whether you get that result will be
based first.
He have clarity.
Think about it.
You can look at any business and if you
want to know what shifts a business,
which shifts your life,
there's one force decision making.
Decision making is the force that shapes
destiny,
personal,
corporate,
business,
destiny.
How many of you can think of Disney?
The decisions that you made years ago,
one or two decisions five,
10 15 years ago that that decision you
may not have realized at the time,
but that decision was one of the most
important decisions of your life.
You've made a different decision there.
You're going a different direction in
your life would be completely different
today.
Who can relate to this and made him,
I say hi,
secret then is getting darn good and
making more effective decisions?
No,
by the way,
are we always going to make the right
decision?
Yes or no?
Absolutely not.
No way in a million years,
but most people don't have the guts to
make the tough decisions because they
want to make the right decision.
So they make notices and that's a
decision.
Is it a true?
And what happens is the world takes them
over.
So decision making is the power.
Now,
there's three decisions you're making
every moment of your life and of your
business and making it right now in this
room,
and if you're watching here on film
especially,
you might make some decisions because
there's,
you're not in the environment that's
different,
but the first decision you're making
every moment your life,
it affects your life and businesses.
What are you going to focus on?
Because whenever you focus on,
you're going to feel so as a business
owner,
every employee you have,
each day comes in and they make
decisions about what the focus on.
Some people focus on their own needs.
Some people focus on the customer's
needs is not going to change the quality
of what your business does,
how it does,
yes or no,
a little or completely,
completely.
Some people focus on what they can't
control every day.
Can you predict?
If you're focusing every day on what you
can't control,
how you're going to feel about your life
or your business,
you're going to be overwhelmed.
You're going to be depressed,
you're going to be frustrated.
Right now,
you're deciding what to focus on.
You can be focusing on,
okay,
we're getting into it now.
I got the energy,
now we're going to get into the meat of
this.
You're right.
All business is decision making,
better decisions,
better life.
Or You'd be saying,
wow,
my neighbor's smells after all that
jumping up and down,
notice that focus,
right?
Whenever you focus on,
you're gonna experience though.
True.
Now some people make a decision and then
they focus on the decision about how it
didn't work out versus what they
learned.
Because we're going to be plenty of
decisions that don't work out back.
Probably for your honest,
most of us forget them,
but most of their decisions aren't
necessarily the right decisions if we
make gutsy ones.
But the open decision is the ability to
choose again.
So focus is a decision.
It's happening right now.
It's happening in your business.
But here's what we're looking for.
There's a pattern of focus at some
stages in business is you're gonna learn
today the focus of the entrepreneur and
the business is increasing sales and
increased sales,
increased sales.
And when they're successful,
they eventually fail because their sales
are increasing.
But what's not someone telling me what's
not profits?
Some people are totally focused on
profits,
profits.
Can you make any company profitable?
Yes or no?
Sure.
You can cut enough stuff.
You can make any company profitable for
a while,
a day,
a week,
a month,
a year,
a decade,
true.
At different stages in the business,
you must change your focus.
There's a life cycle to a business.
If you're going to make effective
decisions,
you've got to know where you are on that
lifecycle.
You make decisions differently for a
teenager than a toddler than a grown
adult,
don't you?
Same thing's true in the business and
your life,
so if you're going to control your life,
the way you take controls by making new
choices,
if you don't like how things are,
when you got to do change it and to
change it,
you have to make a decision.
And by the way,
leaders make decisions.
That's what makes somebody a leader.
They have the guts to make the most
difficult decision.
Nobody else has the guts to make and
they know they're going to be wrong,
but if they're wrong,
what will they do?
They'll know what they want,
they see it's not working and they'll do
what?
Change it,
which means don't make another decision,
do something new and see if it works.
That's the essence of how we grow.
So first assisting controls your life is
focus.
Lots of patterns.
Some people focus on what they control.
Some focus on what they can't control.
Some focus on customers,
as I said,
some focus on themselves.
If you let me this whole business about
meeting your needs,
you can run a successful business,
but it will be a job because you'll
never be able to sell it because it was
just meeting your needs.
It's not a system.
It demands your attention.
We your connection.
It's giving what you want,
but ultimately it's not going to give
somebody else what they want so he can't
sell it.
If you can't sell your business,
if you don't have an exit strategy,
you have a job.
I don't care how successful the
businesses,
he doesn't mean you have to sell the
business,
but one of the most important decisions
you make in business is ultimately,
if I was going to sell this by chose to,
I have to know who,
what I sell this to so that I have
longterm value,
not just an income or walking away.
I have this critical mass,
yet I got a multiple of my business and
most people don't have a clear exit
strategy.
They think all come up with that some
day.
You're going to start with that end in
mind.
That's gotta be part of your focus.
If you're gonna be successful in your
business.
I can remember,
um,
gentlemen has built ca and Hollywood is
largest,
most successful agency,
right?
Michael Ovitz,
remember that name?
He put together Nike and Coca Cola and
these billion dollar deals and
eventually Mike Ovitz went to go sell
that business.
He'd never thought through an exit
strategy and he got almost nothing for
it because the laws prevented him from
selling it to a studio.
He had to sell it to some of his
employees for pennies on its real value.
No,
Mike found a way to make money later on
in another place off of Disney.
But the bottom line is the guy didn't
have an exit strategy and there was
brilliant,
made lots of money in the end,
didn't get the value focus.
Your first decision is what are you
going to focus on?
The second decision,
the minute you focused on something,
you're going to feel it.
So if you focus on,
oh my God,
the economy's coming apart,
my industries,
you know,
people are not buying my product or
service,
they're shutting it down.
Consumers are not spending the money.
Is that going to affect your state?
Yes or no?
Now should you lie to yourself and just
pretend there aren't challenges?
No,
but you're going to have to focus
instead on what am I gonna do?
What's the need that's still there in
any marketplace?
There's all one still people buying.
I've seen it throughout the years.
Even in some simple little business.
Let's say you're a realtor,
you have your own little real estate
office or you kind of your own
salesperson.
You've got a couple of people that work
with you that help you leverage
yourself.
Some got simple.
I remember years ago I met a woman named
Marty Rodriguez.
She's from the town I grew up in.
She came and one of my seminars and that
she be sitting in front row and I did in
a year.
I made done 25 seminars.
She was probably at 10 of them,
same seminar in front of low.
This is the woman who was the number one
real estate agent for century 21 in the
free world,
nine out of 11 years.
I watched her in good times,
make money in the worst times,
make money.
A few years ago,
she sold more real estate in the city.
She's from than the entire multiple
listing service of other agents
combined.
One person now she built into a
business.
It's got a whole team that runs it,
but it still hurt.
She built the brand.
How does he do well when it's going
horrible?
She says,
I love when the economy gets terrible
because it gets rid of all those flaky
realtors,
all those flaky mortgage brokers,
there are so many of them.
They got in,
the business was going up and they all
got successful because they're on a
trend.
When the train crashed,
they all left and left me all the
business.
She loves these times,
but the reason that's her focus is
different.
Does that make sense?
Completely different focus.
So when you're focusing,
you've got to decide what I'm going to
focus on.
But as soon as you focus on something,
even if it's not true,
you're going to feel it.
So if you think someone tells you,
someone screwed you over,
they took advantage of you and you're
like,
what?
And you're all upset and you picture in
your mind and now you're angry,
and then later you've got to confront
this person.
You find out it wasn't true.
Who's ever had some like this happened?
It felt like an idiot.
Raise your hand and say hi.
But when you focus on it,
does it control you?
Do you feel it,
yes or no?
So just write fun.
Focus equals feeling.
Whatever you focus on,
you're going to feel.
And as a leader,
you're gonna have to manage those
feelings and you gotta do it by managing
your focus.
By the way,
if you can lead other people,
do you have to create a focus for the
company,
for the organization to be successful?
Yes or no?
You've got to find yourself.
What are people focusing on?
It's affecting all the decisions in the
company.
So as soon as you focus on that,
finally get to decision number two.
Decision number two is what does this
mean?
When you focus on somebody got up to get
him to meaning.
Is this the end or the beginning?
If you think this is the end of your
business,
the end of opportunity,
the end of our economy,
are you going to feel differently and
act differently than if you think it's
the beginning?
Yes or no?
See the difference between Joe Kennedy
with 4 million bucks in 1929 and Joe
Kennedy when 180 plus million dollars in
1932 that big a jump,
different focus,
different meaning when everybody else
said it was the end and it we're
focusing on how to survive.
He was focusing on how to take market
share.
He was focusing on what the
opportunities,
where the meaning for him was.
Is this the greatest opportunity of my
lifetime?
They'll never be another time like this
and he made enough money in that time
that took care of all his heirs after
that for decades to come all because he
had a different focus in a different
meaning.
Listen,
if you're in an intimate relationship
and you think it's the end of that
relationship,
are you going to treat that person the
same way as if you think it's the
beginning?
Yes or no?
No.
Somebody's laughing over here.
They know no way,
but you know what?
In the beginning of a relationship,
what will you do for somebody you love
what we do for him?
Come on.
What?
What if they say,
would you take out the trash?
What do you say?
I'll take up the trash of course.
What else would you like me to do?
Isn't it true after three or four years,
they say a five or seven.
They go,
we take out the trash first.
He goes,
what do I look like?
Your janitor?
I don't know what it is.
We don't seem to have same attraction.
I don't know what happened.
Here's,
I tell people,
treat people at the end of the
relationship,
like it's the beginning and it won't be
in it.
And that's not just your intimate
relationship.
What if your customers,
what if you fell in love with your
customers,
with your clients more than your
product,
more than your company?
If your entire life was about meeting
their needs,
if you would do what for your customers,
clients,
you would do what?
If you love your customers and clients,
you'd do anything.
Guess what?
They're going to love you.
But most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them,
do what they want,
respond to them.
And,
um,
they don't,
they don't that the end.
You want clients for life,
not just customers fall in love with
them.
It's a different focus isn't it?
It's a different meaning and that
creates a different life because you
make decisions differently from that
place.
There's another meaning.
You know,
is this punishment in my business?
Am I being punished by God or am I being
challenged or is this actually a gift?
What I'm facing right now?
Whatever meaning you give controls what
you feel and what you feel controls the
third decision,
what are you going to do?
Right?
The minute you give it a meaning,
you get a feeling.
When you get,
you know,
a feeling you're going to do something,
you're going to take action,
you're gonna pull back.
A whole economy is driven by this.
People start focusing on,
oh my God,
maybe this is going to go on forever.
Maybe I'm not going to get what I need.
This might be the end of the way things
are.
I've been a pull in my reins.
I better not spend this money I've been
or not take any action.
It becomes a self fulfilling prophecy.
How many know what I'm talking about it?
So decision making is your power.
You want to change your business.
Think about whatever's changed your
business in the past.
I guarantee which change your business
is.
Some decisions you made,
you made some decisions that shifted
your business in a radical way,
changed things in a way that shifted the
game for you.
Decisions about people,
decisions about products,
decisions about marketing or promotion,
decisions about locations,
decisions about what you're going to
offer,
your offerings,
decisions you want to change your whole
business.
You can do it next few days just with
some new decisions,
but you're going to get stimulated.
All kinds of decisions.
Look at got to decide which ones will
make the biggest difference today.
Again,
it's going to help you understand where
those decisions need to be focused based
on where you are in the lifecycle of
your business and where you are in your
personal life cycle.
By the way,
you make decisions differently.
You'll look at time differently when
you're 20 than when you're 30 and when
you're 40 and when you're 50 then when
you're 60 then when you're 70 yes or no,
it'll affect your decisions.